こんにちははじめ社長です皆さんフルーツ好きですか
そしてフルーツで作られたフルーツジュース好きですか
立っ
あっはぁそうかそっかーーーんみんな大好きか
僕も大好きなんだ恋絶滅惜しくないですか夏のフルーツこれ一本
見てもう入ってるフルーツの量がすっごくいっぱい
vics ブーツじぇせていいよね1回のだけたくさんのフルーツの味が楽しめてから
とーっても美味しいんだじゃあいただきます
ん
ああああああ
まあ本当に美味しいんですよフルーツジュースこれが目立ってビンゴココナツ米
アップルマンゴーパッショングループばならがまだ1瓶と缶カム
彼女もやテロらぁ祭大量のクルーズが楽しめるのは降りずミックスジュースの特徴なん
ですけどもね最近みんなで話しててふと話題になったんですけどもう
スーツで全部混ぜてもまずい説があるんですよ
よく考えてみてください
国今まで動画で色んなもの混ぜてきましたあれとこれを混ぜたらおいしいんじゃないか
これとこれは混ぜたらおいしいんじゃないか
その混ぜるほどの数が増えれば増えるほど不味くなっています私は経験ぞそうなんです
つまりフレーズも一緒でこういうフルーツジュースってですね実はですねあの混ぜて
ないんですよ
ff 13混ぜてないですこんなたくさん混ぜるとさ
菅に変化して美味しいわけじゃないんですよねこれはおいしいよに作ってる偽りの世界
とやって実際こんなにフルーツがあるともいろんな味がありすぎてどれも美味しいん
ですけど混ぜると絶対喧嘩になるフルーツは全部混ぜてもまずい
今から証明しようと思いますねえか開いてくださっすぐ今から合体させるフルーツを
紹介していきましょう
もうなんかスーパー
ネメアたに4台持って行きましたまずはこちらマナー
なしか青リンゴでアコレンタルマスカットですねアウェイ
えばっても何にマジでわからないです
わかんなんだけど書いてため店みたいなことをやっていきますればソウルだめだそれ
ダウン相成ってるまんっ
グレープ別グレープフルーツもなかっ
期間限定モデル覆うで10杯もない追加ですね
me
15すごいですねすばせです15それやると完全にフルーツミックスチューブに何か
間違いなしだが現実はそう私はありません多分まずいです
みんな喧嘩します間違いないですが早速混ぜていきましょう
さあ問題は僕フルーツを切ったことないんでどうやって言ってるかわかんないですよね
それで入れそうなやつから揺れていきましょうか
まずバナーです
ちょっと入れてきましたねスイカも食べですね簡単に入ると思いますよっ
何そんな姉母ほぼ成分なんでも酷されると思いたいところではありますね
まあ今でいるすぎ
ame
me
心臓目がーまるごと1個入れましょうマスカットでも彼は奈落へた気がするんだよその
まま会でと来てことはブルーベリーもその計算とである歌もそのままいけると思うんだ
けども入れますさあここがでちょっと六区制が増えてきますねまず先にこのエーザイの
しれないなんだっけそれで一種みたいなと植えていきますがすごいすごい
果物を買い宝石やでこれするっていけそうなんでこのままも多い
入っちゃいましょうりんごはさせねえ分かります剣崎でくださいね
それぞれを待ってます
踊った
水みんな真似しないでください
はい中でもきっちり探したら b らがあったのでこれで多分ほとんどですがパラなっ
ていけそうな気がします
桃
ん
まさかこれしたいよか
2位ていると分かったお世話で無知でやばいんだような料理とか全く知らないんで
ちょっとこの中にフルーツ大好きな方いいからほんともうすぎない半分ぐらいでいいん
じゃないかな
言葉まくったほうがぜってーまだわからないからね英語とばずっとに向いた方が早い
ですよね
これ少ないうんうわぁなんかこれ多分着る日がてるなぁ
目がぁ思い出したパーちゃん行ってだおばあちゃんはこうやって切ってねこんなんだっ
た気がする
ダーバンで本当に目に入った山へ多分も大勢こんな方で大丈夫だと思います
待って多すぎんどんどんいきます
んだからほな伸ばし bot がいい気がするんだよなぁ
絶対これが正しいスレで絞れるのは絞って入れますなどで混ぜる前提だったんだろうし
う y 色してねーこれも絞っちゃいます
この星がダメのあんま見たことないんだよなこれどうするんだろう
たヴィットリオだしていきますねああ
あっはうわーうわーそあんだよねメロン嫌いだった
メロンパンとか好きなんですねメロンあんまり好きじゃないんですよ german な
形で切り抜けないと駄目って習った気がする
[音楽]
なんかメロンやばいなあなたまっっ
スゴランドだけラッピングされてやっぱ18金なり
魚絶対うまい
万劫まじうまいすんあれだと空想の塔だけ入れましたそして最後ですね
鳥と嬉しいものを見たことないよ
あぶなまつげ猫の髪の毛は最初に切り落とすべきところであろうというのを知ってい
ます
a 5 a 5ばかりの google 人生なぁ
四電は館内で google で調べますパイナップルの切り方を教えて
長方形に次へとスってやっぱ最初に治療しなきゃいけないんだろうねええ
[音楽]
こうしてカットフルーツはできるんです愛される無事すべてのフルーツが中に入りまし
た
これを混ぜて飲むとこれこと真のフルーツジュースですから話で本当のフルーツ
ジューサー美味しいのか美味しくないのか
今から確かめようと思います真島
[音楽]
もっとぐざきちゃってなると思ったんですけど早速別ちゃんと法も
曲は黒いなぁ可能で美味しくしたりでちょっと不純物を取り除きますネット上流
待て選ばれるひとつ来なくないはいっていうわけで完成しました
果たしてこれは美味しいんでしょうか美味しくないのでしょうか
いただきます
[音楽]
うん
いいまあ
[音楽]
me
バッハ
さては果肉入ってたかおいしーかー
はぁっ
甘い系証券かー
フルーツは混ぜても美味しいということが分かりましたやっぱちゃんと美味しいんだな
快適で皆さんお店切っているフルーツミックスジュースとかとほぼ一緒の味がしました
マジでも資格ですみなさんぜひぜひやってみてください
まあフルーツ合計5000円だったんですけどねぇ